make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay we're getting into uncanny x-men
annual number one and we don't normally
cover annuals on this channel and the
reason why is because they're usually
not essential like it might be a
flashback issue or it might be something
that goes on that has nothing to do with
the existing story and can be totally
left out but momma doesn't do that here
and there's a couple reasons why I'm
inclined to believe that they're they're
doing it this way first of all it's
because for one they're literally like
kind of trying to return the x-men to
the way they used to be but then also
Marvel's kind of like filling the x-men
titles to the brim which can be a good
or a bad thing but what this does is it
essentially deals with like the return
of Cyclops right that was kind of the
cool thing at the end of the first run
the first arc of uncanny x-men Cyclops
came back but we didn't know how he was
just there and it was just kind of like
okay so like Cyclops is alive now
someone tell me what the heck is going
on and so what this does is it an
initially kind of flashes back to some
point previous to this era in time so
how we go as far as to say this arc
probably takes place during the time of
like Chris Claremont run on x-men but
basically it deals in like Cambridge
Massachusetts and there's just this
professor who's just kind of being a
dick the idea behind this guy and this
this is it's actually kind of cool to
see Ed Burris and do this the idea
behind this guy is that he was a
professor at the school and the students
were terrace as he explains the students
were scared of his big idea and so they
ratted him out to the Dean the Dean took
his lab and then fired him and the guys
just going on like a vendetta it's like
the simplest plot ever but again it's
cool to see Britten do this because like
this is how villains were usually
written back then like small-time
villains you just kind of got like a
small story like you were to sort of a
step on film which is to say a
villainous use in order to be stepped on
to kind of keep the plot going it's kind
of cool to see ed Burton do this is
actually pretty interesting to kind of
see a throwback but in the midst of all
this Cyclops is met by a guy named Paul
and essentially Paul was like gonna be
killed in like this onslaught of the
robots and the result was that with
Cyclops saving his life Paul's basically
like look man I owe you a favor I'll
return it anytime you want to and so
what we do is we jump forward ten years
later in Paul's met by the arrival of
kid Cable now a little bit of
explanation is needed here back when
Bendis was when he really came on and
wrote like all new x-men what he did is
he wrote an arc that basically saw x-men
from the past brought to the future by
beast in order to like remind Cyclops of
what the x-men used to stand for because
by that point in time Cyclops his
character had been written to become
more militaristic and extreme
is kind of like you've lost your way I
want to remind you of what's going on
the problem with this is that the way
Bendis wrote it is that it almost seemed
like they were brought from like the
past of a different universe and so it
was kind of weird it kind of went back
and forth ultimately Marvel's settle on
the fact that they were like from the
past so the main Marvel Universe and so
that was kind of a way to like keep them
there for a little bit
but ultimately while it was cool
initially they were kind of characters
like nobody really knew what to do with
them they were just sort of just
occupying a space in a Kalibak landscape
and they were just kind of there and so
part of this whole reshuffling with like
the relaunch of uncanny x-men is to
literally eliminate all those ties and
so after the events of x-men read what
Marvel did is they launched
extermination well it was like
extinction in the next termination and
what extermination did was basically
send the time displace x-men back to
their own past but then it also had like
cable killed and what this does is it
allows Marvel to basically bring in this
younger version of cable who's still
from the future and then basically say
like they're gonna wipe away everything
cable did or what-have-you but
essentially remove him from that role
and say this is essentially like a clean
slate but young cable showing up here is
basically telling Paul hey look you've
got to repay the favor that you gave to
Cyclops that you would help him out at
some point along the line that you were
basically like repay the fact that he
saved your life and so what Young Cable
had done is he has certainly brought in
this box it was designed to house the
Phoenix now this is kind of a throwback
to the old Secret Avengers tie-in from
issue number 26 I think it was from the
Avengers vs. x-men crossover the idea
was that when Avengers vs. x-men kicked
off those you guys should never read
that when Avengers vs. x-men kicked off
it was predicated on the idea that the
Phoenix force was coming back and it was
gonna bond itself to Hope Summers who
was like the newest mutant born after
the events of house of M when the
Scarlet Witch took everybody's Newton
powers away and so the fear of the
Avengers and humanity as a whole was
that if the Phoenix came back and it
bonded itself to Hope Summers there they
would basically see a return of like the
Dark Phoenix but the Dark Phoenix would
lose its mind like it did with Jean Grey
it would go crazy and just sort like
killing everything and going but you
know going bananas nobody knew what
would happen
and so this led to kind of a rift
between the Avengers in the x-men when
the Avengers showed up on the x-men
doorstep and said give us Hope Summers
and the x-men said no and they basically
started battling each other while all
that was going on what you had is you
had various groups you had like Captain
America's Secret Avengers team and you
had like Iron Man and so on and so forth
you had them trying to find ways to like
contain or destroy the Phoenix and one
of the ideas they came up with was
literally this little box it was going
to be designed for the purpose of
housing the Phoenix
itself to be used at a later date or to
have its energy Channel or something
along those lines which is kind of nuts
because with all the power the phoenix
possesses it's a multiversal entity it's
like it's like creating a cosmic cube
but with kid Kayla showing up here the
response he basically makes is your job
is to basically make this box work and
then reduce it in size to like a very
very minuscule version and then cable
just leaves and so what happens is
jumping forward to the first time that
Cyclops died about two years later Hall
and kid cable essentially like go to
where Cyclops is at now the reason why I
say the first time Cyclops died is
because this was part of the the
publishing era when wawel was trying to
basically like blackballed the x-men
they were trying to get Marvel
readership to care about the Inhumans
something that would never happen ever
ultimately Marvel killed off Cyclops in
the worst way possible he basically died
from terrigenesis he was exposed to the
Terrigen mists of like the Inhumans and
it killed him one of the worst ideas
ever in the history of public of like
hummable publishing it was a terrible
idea but nonetheless what they end up
doing here is showing up and basically
like bonding this little miniature you
know Phoenix entrapping device into the
body of Cyclops now the reason why this
happens is because remember kid cables
for the future and so we knows
everything that's gonna transpire now
this right here as much as I love Ed
Britain as a writer this right here
begins to kind of show the flaw and
having cable exists in Marvel Comics
cable is a character of convenience if a
writer wants to achieve a goal and they
can't really make the goal work through
any normal means by just writing they'll
bring cable in and then suddenly
everything will be okay and you guys
will see what I mean by the time we get
to the end of this now with regards to
this scenario literally like this tiny
little Phoenix entrapping device putting
it inside the body of Cyclops and
leaving it there what it does is it fast
forwards yet again and this goes into
Phoenix resurrection the return of Jean
Grey now we have covered that video on
my channel you guys are welcome to check
it out but the idea is that that Jean
Grey essentially was resurrected and
when she came back to life she had
literally used like the power of the
Phoenix to essentially like create this
sort of pocket reality for herself in a
sense it like on earth everything she
ever knew was kind of resurrected in
this small little middle of nowhere
location and when that happened what it
did is it brought Cyclops back to life
at the end of the story when Jean
realized what was going on and tried to
cast off the Phoenix and so in an effort
to get Jean to keep the Phoenix wither
the Phoenix resurrected Cyclops and said
this is the life that you can have
together now this is why why it is a kid
Kable had that device installed in
cyclops because when that happens what
the device does is start to siphon off
some of the Phoenix's power and I
remember the Phoenix represents the sum
total of all life that has ever
currently does and will ever exist in
Marvel Comics in the Marvel multiverse
what that means is that use in the power
of the Phoenix a person can be
resurrected and that's what ends up
happening here that with Cyclops
quote-unquote dying a second time as if
he was ever alive in the first place
with that power of the Phoenix being
instilled inside his chest it resurrects
him and that's what ends up bringing him
back is literally the power of the
Phoenix but it creates a kind of Tony
Stark concept here and the reason why I
say that is because there's no
indication the devices that are removed
and the implication seems to be that if
it is Cyclops would die again so it's
kind of a cool little little little
concept here you know a little caveat
with the return of his character but
showing up and having the whole scenario
explained to him by Kidd Cable by Paul
it is a little bit to take on at one
particular point in time but basically
where Cyclops wants to leave and rejoin
the x-men the responsive kid cable is no
and so what this means is that during
the events of x-men x-men red.when like
Cassandra Nova's doing her whole thing
during the events of of like x-men when
like Nate gray comes back and basically
like starts doing all these crazy things
Cyclops is alive during all of that and
so what this does is it put it allow
skid cable to put Cyclops in a very
precarious situation where Cyclops wants
to leave kid cable won't let him go not
only that kid cable also basically says
my job is to keep the timeline secure
that was the problem with the older
future version of myself is that he
would just kind of hop back and forth
through time and screw up the timestream
my job is to be a lot more hands-off to
make sure the timestream doesn't get
messed up the way that it was before and
when when Cyclops asked the question
well if your job isn't accrues screw up
the timestream why are you back here
that's when kid cable basically admits I
did it for selfish reasons and that's
why I say like I love what EDD Brisson
is doing here but it's also kind of a
dangerous line because if a motion is
involved in the reason for why cable did
what he did in terms of how he's written
and what it means is that like he's
inherently an emotional character if
something happens in Marvel Comics that
kid cable has a personal stake in then
like he would go back in time and he
would basically fix it or he would allow
it to be adjusted it basically D ages
cable but like the role he plays is
still the same at the moment you kind of
have to see where Edison's run goes and
see what happens but it's a Pandora's
box kind of situation I do like the
concept I am excited to see where it
goes and so what is up happening
is where the two of them basically kind
of make amends kid cable says I will let
you go but first you have to pass the
test what you have going on here are two
different scenarios at the moment the
doctor who went crazy the the robot guy
who went crazy has been released from
jail and he's plotting his revenge
against Paul who has a wife and kids at
the same time your x-men are facing off
against Nate gray and so what will
happen is one of two things either you
can go to your x-men and you can fight
alongside them but if they lose they
will die but you can also go and you can
save Paul and if Paul dies being a
basically failing a guy so if you
succeed if you help the other you fail
the other and that's kind of the cool
scenario here because the questions ask
which one do you pick and so what
Cyclops ends up doing is going and
rescuing Paul and that's what Natan
that's that's what cable was looking for
him to do or so basically say look I
trust my x-men they've made it this far
without me they can survive this fight
without me they don't necessarily need
me there and this is very very important
because what this does is it kind of
bring Cyclops back to the version that
so many people know things never ever
ever change forever they always go back
to the status quo they always go back to
their original models and that's what
Cyclops is doing here is the way he's
being written by Ed brisance Cyclops had
to make the choice between fighting
alongside the x-men and taking out Nate
gray which his revolutionary version
would have done or he goes back to being
the version he was before when he was
the prodigious student of Xavier he was
the boy scout and he goes and saves the
innocent guy which is exactly what he
does here and so he goes back he saves
Paul and then basically says like my job
now is to go and reunite with the x-men
my job now is to go back and find that
team and see what role I need to play is
a pretty cool thing and it's pretty
awesome because what it does is it sets
the stage for the return of Cyclops to
rejoin the x-men but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to comics
explain and make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the rock or
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]